on this episode of the falcon and the
winter soldier
lemon shrimp coconut shrimp pepper
shrimp
shrimp soup shrimp stew shrimp
salad fire up that shrimp boat and test
out your vibranium arm because we have
marvel's latest series the falcon in the
winter soldier
in this video we'll be taking a deep
dive into episode 1
so if you're not looking for spoilers
just say the same exact thing my parents
do when i asked them to watch one of my
videos
no no i don't think i will
i'll be going over that new cap reveal
and how all the trailers and promo
materials that came before it
fit in with this episode and offer us
clues as to what direction this series
could take
so strap on in make sure to like and
subscribe because here
we go insert iron man joke here sam
wilson aka the falcon is getting ready
for his big speech at the smithsonian
air and space museum
you'll see he's wearing the same suit as
we'll later see him wearing at the event
you may have also
noticed the louisiana state pennant on
the wall suggesting this is at the home
he and his sister
sarah own in delaware louisiana and you
know sometimes my deep dives can go a
little too deep but delaqua
translates from french to of the cross
which could be a subtle
reference to christ's sacrifice on the
cross just like falcon will need to make
sacrifices over the course of this
season
subtle got it and it happens to be a
real place
he's holding on to captain america's
shield which was given to him by
cap himself steve rogers at the end of
avengers end game
in voiceover we hear cap's conversation
to sam about giving him the shield
how's it feel like it's someone else's
it isn't and that's the big character
arc for falcon this season
coming to terms with who he is and
continuing captain america's legacy
and legacy is also reflected in his
personal life as he argues with his
sister about not selling his parents
shrimping boat the first minute of the
show has already set up how this series
will likely
end falcon will embrace the shield a
symbol of everything
captain america stood for and take up
that mantle but also run a successful
bubba gumps
let's zip halfway around the world to
tunisian airspace where falcon is tasked
with rescuing a u.s air force captain
by the name of assange he's been taken
hostage by a group known as
laf we never do find out what laf stands
for but they're a high-powered criminal
organization
with paraspecialists proficient in
advanced wingsuit technology
now falcon is told to keep things subtle
the us military doesn't want to be
associated with this mission but as
we'll find out
yeah subtlety is in his strong suit
falcon is partnered with joaquin torres
who looks like he'll be falcon and
bucky's quote unquote man on the ground
for much of the season and when i mean
man on the ground yeah
as falcon infiltrates the hijacked
aircraft he finds that the criminals are
led by none other than
georges batroc who you may remember from
captain america the winter soldier where
he hijacked the lumerian star
he was last seen interrogated in winter
soldier so we're not exactly sure what
happened to him between his capture
and the events occurring right now it's
possible he escaped
made a deal or if he was taken during
the blip or reappeared out of his
confines but truck taunted captain
america
asking him if he's more than just his
shield why into the prison
to which cap responded by finding him
hand to hand
it's kind of ironic since that's exactly
what falcon will later do hinting again
that captain america
is more than just a shield one of the
main themes of this series
and in the marvel universe but trock
even beats his chest here just like he
does with his fight against cap we'll
see falcon use his wings in really
unique and interesting ways throughout
the season
like him using it as a shield to deflect
bullets plus his little drone red wing
which we see able to carve its way into
the hijacked plane
but trock and his men are able to escape
with captain bassant and i'm watching
all this action like
falcon has to get vasant back before
they get into libyan airspace or else
there's going to be hell to pay
and using some nifty maneuvering he's
able to shake off those pesky
heat-seeking missiles
and simultaneously capture his target
now the last we see at batrock he
escapes the chopper before it explodes
so it's totally possible we might see
him later on in the series
i also noticed this insect symbol on his
wingsuit i wasn't able to find any
marvel connection here but if you happen
to know what it could mean i'd love to
hear it in the comments
as far as episode 1 is concerned this
mission so far has little impact on the
main story
it was basically the show's way of
getting our adrenaline pumping
showing off where falcon is at the
moment and establishing a few things
that are going on in the world which
leads us to tunisia where we learn a lot
about how things have changed
after half the world returned after the
blip an event we last saw briefly in
wandavision
and the return of monica rambo falcon
repairs what torres calls his stark
level tech we learn
falcon speaks fluent arabic and for the
past six months has been working for the
air force
taurus here sets up what appears to be
the main conflict of the season
a rogue group called the flag smashers
are wreaking havoc across the globe
using what appears to be some sort of
augmented reality to get their manifesto
and message
out there their symbol is a globe in a
palm something we'll see on their masks
later on in the episode the flank
smashers believed that the world was
better during the blip
and that the world should be unified
without borders we also see a man thank
falcon at avenger for his help in
getting his wife back
that's a bit of an age gap i i thought
it was his daughter back in washington
sam delivers a speech in remembrance of
captain america where he has chosen to
hand
over the shield it's here he talks about
how its symbol was only as good as the
man who propped it up it's also here we
learn
sam's flaw he believes the future relies
on new heroes to continue on the legacy
failing to see his own words that it's
who's behind the shield that makes it
what it is it doesn't need a new hero it
needs someone who can maintain the honor
and integrity that
cap gave that shield it needs sam but it
will take him a few more episodes to
realize that
or at least that's where i think it's
headed in attendance is james rhodes aka
war machine who walks with sam through
the captain america exhibit you can see
a little history of bucky and how he
fell off the train in 1944 and later was
found to be a brainwashed hydra
operative known as the winter soldier
there are nods to cap's motorbike
the vanished from the blip new york
under attack and thanos's giant ring
hovering over the city
there's even the real captain america
comic over here james asked sam why he
didn't pick up the mantle responding
that it belongs to steve but if the
world is broken looking for someone to
fix it as
james suggests sam is going to have to
change this mentality he says he'll be
in touch so this likely won't be the
last we see of him
as we're left with a not so subtle shot
of sam in a literal reflection of
captain america's suit
i gotta say this part had me in the
first half as we have a flashback slash
nightmare featuring bucky during his
time as the winter soldier yeah they had
us the first half i'm not gonna lie
here he is taking down a group of men
with ease and even kills the civilian
one who will later find out is his
friend yori nakajima's son
it's easy to assume that part of the
reason bucky hangs out with yori is due
to the guilt he feels for killing his
son
part of bucky's arc this season will be
reconciling his past
and moving on with his life and as we'll
see that's easier said than done
waking up from his nightmare we see he
still wears his dog tags the ones he
wore
while part of the howling commandos even
though he's a civilian now he still has
this soldier mentality he's also a
chronic liar telling his therapist that
he isn't having nightmares that he's
following the rules and trusts people
as part of his mandated therapy part of
his pardon he has to make amends with
people who wronged him or
he wronged but he has to follow three
rules one
he can't do anything illegal what the
hell
two nobody gets hurt and three tell them
he's here to make amends
i'm no longer the winner soldier i'm
james bucky barnes and you're
part of my efforts to make amends on his
list we'll see a selection of names most
of them we've never heard of in the
marvel universe before
aside from h zemo referring to helmut
zemo the former sokovian colonel who
framed bucky barnes for the bombing
which killed the wakandan king to chaka
an event which was the catalyst for
avengers civil war
as seen in the trailers helmut does make
an appearance in this series which is
very interesting since the last we saw
him he was in custody after being
captured by black panther
bucky's therapist says an interesting
line here you're going to have to open
up and understand that some people
really do
want to help you and that they can be
trusted hinting that the person he'll
one day trust
is the man he'll soon be teamed up with
falcon in fact he's been ignoring calls
from sam
with cap gone bucky is all alone and the
therapist says
and if you are alone that is the
quietest
most personal hell and james
it is very hard to escape so him
eventually going on a date set up by mr
nakajima
is definitely a step in the right
direction i think it's an interesting
choice to have him framed against the
wall of trees here
like someone lost in a forest he'll
later literally fall in a forest but
that could just be a coincidence
yuri and bucky go out for japanese it's
a bit ironic since bucky fought against
the japanese in the 40s yori is reading
the obituaries remarking how no one made
it past
90. interesting since bucky later tells
leah over here he's
and hasn't danced since 1943. it's here
nakajima tells bucky about the
mysterious death of his son and the
thing that haunts him the most
is never knowing why it happened as
we'll later find out when bucky sees the
shrine
yori has for his son bucky was the
killer although it was while he was
brainwashed as the winter soldier will
later find out that nakajima
is also on bucky's list to make amends
in louisiana sam visits his sister sarah
and two nephews at their family seafood
business this boat was left to them
after their parents death and with sam
having been gone in the blip
sarah kept the business afloat and yes
that's a pun over the years
the problem is it's in financial ruin
and needs money to survive
sarah wants to sell it sam wants to hold
on to the legacy
of course bucky would be down to play a
war game of battleship on his date he
complains about girls having tigers in
their online dating profiles while
drinking tiger beer
you'll also notice the yellow menikoniko
figurine a symbol used to bring a good
luck and fortune
lee remarks how he's old-fashioned for
bringing her flowers well he did grow up
in the 1940s
and we learn a little more about his
family his parents passed away
and he has one sister if i'm not
mistaken this is the first time in the
mcu bucky having a sister is brought up
and notice how he said
has not had if she's still alive she
could be near a hundred but
anything is possible in marvel so i'm
putting a pin in that for now when leah
brings up yuri's dead son
buggy just straight up leaves that's
that's gonna be a terrible way to end a
date as sam and sarah prepare for their
big meeting with the bank i like the
little details the set designers put in
like a drawing of an airplane or the
little aircraft figurines scattered
throughout the house
in switzerland taurus follows those flag
smasher signs like a game of pokemon go
leading him to a bank robbery involving
flag smasher herself
carly morgenthau in the comics flag
smasher was a man named carl morgenthau
we have seen more of this red-haired
woman in the trailers who dons the flag
smasher symbol on her mask along with
other members of the group
among them is this super strong dude
with long hair and black
eyes in the credits he's listed as
dovich and if you want to see what he
looks like without the mask
here he is poor taurus here gets
straight up face stomped so the banker
ends up being more interested in taking
selfies with falcon than actually giving
them a loan i'm not exactly sure how
falcon can't get a loan considering he's
a friggin adventure like
learn from the boys and start milking it
baby okay maybe a bit too far long story
short they're denied the loan the human
torch was denied
a bank loan sam reiterates to sarah that
he won't sell the boat
it's half his and he won't sell their
legacy we're not selling our family's
legacy
taurus calls and updates sam about the
latest flag smasher robbery identifying
dovitch as their leader
however i think this could be a fake out
and that carly is the real leader or at
least a person who is more important
considering the considerable amount of
screen time she's gotten in the trailers
compared to dovich torres says of dovich
before being cut off
do you think he could be a blank is he
referring to someone who could have
superhero abilities or something more as
we've seen in the trailers these flag
smashers can go toe-to-toe with falcon
and bucky possessing the ability to
perform mega leaps extreme agility and
strength
heck he completely picked up taurus and
smashed him to the ground
finally the episode ends with this dude
simply known as government official in
the credits introducing the new
captain america we saw him briefly thank
sam earlier for his donation of the
shield there's not much we know about
this new cap other than his name
john walker sometimes known in the
comics as a us agent now if you go to
the marvel fandom wiki you'll see
dozens of results for this character
that run a huge array of varying paths
and histories
so it's hard to pinpoint where the show
might go with him now i have this gut
feeling that this guy is gonna be the
opposite of what the real captain
america stood for at least
under the surface when he's not running
promo campaigns with marching bands
prompting sam to get that shield back
which we see he does or perhaps he gave
a fake shield to the smithsonian
in the end credits for this new cap you
can make out the graffiti
manufactured hero next to his name
either way i think this new captain
america is going to be either a secret
villain
we do have these shots of him fighting
on top of these trucks while bucky and
falcon are pinned down
as well as him kneeling somewhere that
looks eastern european or he could be a
complete buffoon that doesn't hold a
candle to the real cap he'll be played
by wyatt russell who you may remember
from black mirror
what is like some kind of like a memory
test or something like that also in news
that came out last wednesday kevin feige
has confirmed that chris evans will not
be reprising his role as captain america
is he telling the truth or is this siri
setting up something new entirely i hope
you'll consider liking and subscribing
to the channel as i break down
every episode for more bad takes you can
always follow me on twitter and
instagram at thinkstoryyt
until next time remember daddy loves you
very much